yona des photos qui ont traîné personne
ne veut les acheter donc la presse
people pardon elle est bien plus propre
que certains autres magazines un peu la
mémoire courte il ya dix ans je n'ai pas
fait flasher sur une plage avec les
personnages qui t'aiment suis personne
ne s'en fout car animateur connu des
choses qu'il ya des choses qui gênent
mais on la demi heure
vous étiez photographes avec un
animateur connu je crois que vous dire
même le montant que j'ai touché que tj
grant alors dites nous tout c'est
toucher 16000 euros
parce que vous avez attaqué parce que
j'avais attaqué effectivement j'ai
touché 16000 euros
parce que c'était la première fois qu'on
considérait que c'était de la outings
c'était la première fois qu'un magazine
est en fait pour tout vous dire
closer avait sorti l'histoire politique
avec ségolène royal et du coup voici
voulu faire un gros coup et pauvres
derrière s'est dit tiens on va où ces
quelques heures j'étais avec un
animateur très connu on était très
proches sans médaille était qu'animateur
très connue c'est vrai ça vous a ajouté
exemple ajouté
et pour vous dire la vérité j'étais chez
moi en train d g avec ma soeur et je
vois cette semaine un euro lyonnais
neuro 20 voici machin au matin non alors
nous branle bas de combat j'appelle ma
pauvre homme ma grand mère qui était
chez elle il a fallu planqué tous les
magazines parce qu'on lui a emmené le
samedi tous les magazines sont en
auxiliaires de vie lui en est elle
savait pas que j'étais gay ni rien mais
tout ça pour vous dire que là c'est
parce que yoann outing doivent aller
trop loin le cas des people pardon comme
toi benjamin comme moi et ça vous a pas
vous laisser on n'est rien on n'est rien
ou mois pour moi c'est quand c'est des
vrais vrai qu'à comme schumacher comme
la politique bah ça m'a blessé il est
horrible
imaginez mais vous avez le lendemain
saine et des mauges a touché combien
vous au plus à moi j'ai le bac + moi non
mais comment vous aviez touchée à
l'époque pour ça j'aime bien moi j'ai
pas grand chose parce que comme moi le
prêt que vous voulez la vérité c'est
quoi c'est que quand on est connu
moi avec flavie j'ai fait le choix de
faire des photos mais faux aveux on a
fait des photos de famille enceinte en
effet des photos la maison que terra
donc quand vous donnez
et quand vous ouvrez votre maison
derrière quand vous attaquez n'est pas
grand chose et c'est très normal et
c'est très normal moi aujourd'hui à
temps je n'attaque plus vous avez touché
16000 euros
lorsque vous avez dit il faut toujours
toujours toujours quoiqu'il arrive même
c6 nécro photo attaque et marketing
sinon effectivement ensuite au tribunal
de nanterre où ailleurs ou dire alors
quand ça vous arrange vous attaquez pas
et quand ça vous arrange vous attaquer
moi j'ai toujours toujours attaquer une
fois juge et 5000 euros avec une pub ont
touché du tout chez moi dans ma carrière
peut-être 40000 euros
jean grenet s'est énormément d'argent
énormément d'argent mais croyez moi les
16000 je m'en serais bien passé parce
que bon
alors à ma grand mère ne savait pas et
mes amis savaient pas